Hammer says play me in Duck chess okay
I'll play hammer and duck chess
the stream continues okay it's happening
people it's happening hopefully Hammer
doesn't Farm me
it's happening oh Hammer's also three
two dutches
he wants to play fast I can't play Fast
oh Hammer actually plays this game this
is not the accepted duck Chess Time
control team snipe
let's see how strong he is
okay he's good yeah he's proper good
wait a minute
and I have to be careful super fast
wait what have I done
I haven't played duck chess in a while
to remember the ideas
three is not what is this probably not
the move I should play is this some kind
of new
foreign
faster than I've ever played before
wow he's coming after my I can tell
Hammer is uh
probably more experience than other GMS
at this game
he's going after my pawn and I'm kind of
scared
I actually haven't played too many Grand
Masters in Duck chess
but I played minlay I
I played noraditski
oh Pawn is a little bit weak
that's payback for going after my Pawn
you want to take my Pawn I take your
Pawn
how you like them apples okay things are
getting uh practical
very practical
I do realize there's night here but I
don't think it's a huge issue
okay now there's no 93
I get the chance I should play he got
out of this he tried some kind of a
miracle but yeah we definitely have a
winning position
yeah it's actually been a while since I
played duck chess
if you remember how the duck moves
it's it's probably well over a couple
weeks
I took a small hiatus
uh yeah D4 is a little bit annoying
um I am ready to ascend my Throne space
try and make do with what I have
B3 is my intention we might see duck B3
next
the one the only
duck chest chain from the tree oh I
forgot about that move
oh that's kind of annoying
foreign
yeah this night is uh has some questions
to answer
he's gonna beat me on time
oh
I hate time
ooh
fancy maybe I'll play E4 I need to play
five four no um you hit me with this one
again not even duck I am following for
this one every single time
foreign
thing I have ever seen okay time and
time time again I'm falling for this
bishop Z4 probably coming
he's preventing
at preventing this 95 move
he's he's so much faster probably some
success for that to
Play Bishop takes Knight
ooh fancy
if I play A4 why did I could also just
play
like night after why didn't I just take
while I had the chance oh that was a
mistake D3
I have two ideas
maybe three ideas okay now we have to
back up
three
the goal is to get him low on time it's
so hard to play duck chess uh when
you're low on time
um you're working one
and we have to speed up
I'm trying to take never mind
queen wants to come to F3
foreign
maybe Knight D3
I like the talk on C4 because it blocks
are rook and Bishop
this is not good
and Bishop H3
I gotta put my pieces to work
um
if I have this and then Docker five
guaranteeing upon F5
probably end up trading Rooks
losing on time
yeah five and then duck E7
The Rook is trapped oh
look returns E7
don't see much counter play
I'll save my own Rook just too fast for
me
uh I should probably move the Rook I
want to take on E6 but it doesn't quite
work I will go back to practicing
and I will become faster
just move the Rook
and duck
oh fancy fancy
uh I don't know where I'm moving the
duck at this stage I could take I guess
I take and take
wow
I can also take the Knight
I'll take the Knight
F3
okay traveling the bishop
good game
oh that was close
I play another
yeah no he's that was pretty good
and then
I think I got a little bit outplayed in
the opening which is kind of rare as
white
um
but I just confuse myself
with aligning our Bishops
number two dark I wonder what he's
saying right now
how am I actually gonna have to maybe
use analyze it's the title number two
dog
player ah
oh okay I was beating him like I had a
winning position with the black pieces
oh it's playing which is not easy to
play the same idea that he played
E4 maybe coming wow
oh I messed up I cannot okay I think
generally this is uh
preferable trading okay he must stop the
problem is now both Bishops can develop
but he thinks tonight is worth more than
the bishop
classic mistake
this is how I beat him
this is how I beat him I exploit I don't
know his inaccurate
feelings
about the game
it's important not to like views
is outdated
and he doesn't even know it
okay where's my smothered duck mate
look at this and this
so I'm preventing D5 this is very con
it's a common positional
idea in Duck chess
there's Pawn tension
actually that's not Castle
that's a fair response yeah and
something went wrong here yes
I I think I'm gonna stop putting the I'm
trying to make things more practical
because I can tell he has a very good
positional sense
and positional strategy is a bit
different in Duck chess as well I think
I'm gonna stop putting the the Knight on
okay so it was hitting the pawn he could
have put the duck here no
longer
if I take the bishop
doesn't look great this Knight is
actually a bit
stuck
I could play this
and then I need this
I'm dreaming of smothered duck meat
Queen D3 is a great move
play this and this
you're gonna
okay I have to take now
you really want to play like G6 no I
have to take
[Music]
um
and D5 is coming I'm getting
positionally I'll play it again
it's not pleasant
be this move
trying to guarantee Knight C4
there is no idea to play a five and
doc F6
moving too slowly though
F5 is too weakening
I think I'll just Castle
[Music]
again duck C4
I'll play Knight C5
kingside should be solid
like the duck's a very good Defender
Bishop g7's uh intention
I'm allowing the sack
soccer's may be good but I wasn't sure
ah no
okay he made a mistake he could have
gone here
yeah this is confusing now
I'm gonna put something on E5 but he
might play E5 first
E5 duck F6
but then I get in another five so
there's E5 duck
E4
which I'm trying to make sense of
I think E5 duck E4 is pretty strong
if I take with Bishop
doesn't work
yeah I'm getting squeezed
I think I'm gonna have to play like
Knight B7
okay he doesn't quite find it
also looks like a fine move though
yeah still under a lot of pressure C7
was a Target
okay at least I got the Knight to F5
six
oh I hung a rook
okay
it's not the end of the world though
like weirdly enough
being down a rook
no no no even against someone like
hammer
life still goes on
oh dear
or does it
trying to create some confusion
foreign
[Music]
preventing 93
.
barely got that moving and I just hung a
queen
oh no my queen
does he see it
he sees it
GG
yes yes back to number one back to
number one
title change title oh he's farming me
number one
number one duck chess player
yeah it is rated
okay let's play E4 let's see his uh it's
all about
it's all about suitcase
we just got a
try not
get behind on time
okay no more Mercy
what is he doing
expand on the king's side okay
apparently this is the the Strat and
they just don't know about this one
the H5 makes like
tries to make things very true what do
they know about this one
um care the difference is my Rooks
defended and his Rook is not
should build well so he's gonna have to
keep the dock on the H file
Knight takes is maybe possible
it's confusing though
he wins the bishop I win The Rook
it gets very confusing actually
I mean I guess it is my working theory
that a bishop is better than
yeah so he's going for this
um I think this is called for it's like
guarantee King F2 after he takes
okay so what's happening
like queenh1.g6
so I want to take the bishop
I want to take the Knight maybe actually
I probably don't want to take the bishop
I just want to leave the panda behind on
time
that's a fair move this one should I
have a G8
probably
guarantee and queen G8
yeah sometimes when you're attacking in
Duck chess you want to use the duck
to guarantee your next attacking move
uh Knights
you actually don't mind the trade of
nitro Rook
[Music]
um
I need to go here
this is a key move
also you see if he uh wants to take the
Rook
he doesn't want to take the Rook
hmm
okay I have this maneuver in mind
this Pawn is hanging like he could take
and play Talk A2
it's probably not the best use of time
though
okay so I'm guaranteeing that a five
oh why did I not put it there
Queen has E6 that is so dumb
if I put the duck on I think I can put
the duck on E6
so I want to win this Pawn like Queen
why did I not put it there
it's looking shaky for Bach
oh it's I'm keeping the time Advantage
too
like just three night moves in a row
maybe I'll do is like A5 not putting the
duck where I needed to go with my next
move three times in a row
they're so dumb you could play this and
then duck E7
oh you're just giving me a queen
prizing choice
I mean The Rook is still hanging
oh [ __ ] when he takes it I take his
Bishop
yeah the putting the dock on F7
essentially attacks the g-pawn
oh
okay let's try and trap in the Knight
and the Rook
so this is pure positional play like
going for paralysis
in this and okay now I'm preventing B5
hmm
interesting
eight
I don't know what this next move is
okay I guess he didn't know either
all right he's seven three times for
that yes probably not
okay maybe we'll play one more game
I only have time for one more game yeah
the first two games I was winning this I
see what he's saying again
I stopped putting my duck here
oh he's analyzing move 22 someone's
saying well I mean move 22 I had already
lost my queen like yeah he should have
played Queenie ducky 7. if you want to
talk about something talk about this
moment like here I can just do this yeah
I got five also preventing that F5
where does he want to go like I'm
completely fine here
I just three times in a row I just
allowed him to put the duck on every
Square I wanted to use
I wonder if you could I don't see how
trapping the queen would have changed
anything at that point I had already
lost quite a bit no
again shout out to hammer people should
follow him
I mean what are people on about like
what
okay no more sniping
uh last game for me
okay let's play a Dutch
something in this game yeah that's funny
oops I was kind of a slip but I guess
I'm inviting this and guaranteeing 94.
did he just allow me to do opening
novelty
uh
can I be crazy I think he missed clicked
where he let's play G6
I think that's what happened
uh we have some bad memories with
putting this one here okay this my
stream is ending after this game so
hopefully we'll we'll have a good one
to finish things off
and I'm really going to try and put the
pressure on the clock
I've realized that it's so much better
to save time for later when things get
complicated
ooh fancy fancy
I don't know why this is what can you
change
allow the trade if he wants it
I wonder if he's gonna like try for
Knight C4
not too harmful though
okay trying to skip oh I allowed this
bishop takes B8
did I allow that for the last I allow
that's no
I was allowing it
I guess I couldn't play Pawn D6
yeah I wonder if he doesn't realize the
value of knights over Bishops
because I I think I would have played
takes in a very short amount of time
like he doesn't understand the value of
controlling the center
okay let's take
no let's not take
we have a winning position yet again
let's see how we're gonna screw it up
kind of enough
every game it feels like I'm getting
outplayed in the opening
I'm also placing the duck with no
strategy I don't know why I played dot
D5
it's just about moving quickly though
um maybe at some point
yeah like 95 Bishop
Bishop F6 so I'm threatening the Knight
I've kept both Center pawns back
yeah that's gonna be a bit of a problem
and there's been so much tension between
the Queens
I need a pair of scissors to cut the
tension
oh so he's using a similar idea so I'll
take
and play Let's play this
it's getting spicy if he takes here I
take here
and I could take on
goodbye H5 men
entirely clear what to do here
I want to preserve the night though so
this move looks reasonable
I should have taken that I just want to
say did I not take that
oh
you conduct us
dumbass
I'm along C4 worst case I take the
bishop
uh needed this move
runs into B3 though
okay no this is fine it's just um very
very very low on time
to be preventing that upon from moving
preventing the Bishop from going back
okay three doesn't really work
maybe it does
I just want to play Bishop B7 now C5
activate
interesting
I gotta keep the pace
hmm
I really want to play D5
God will okay we can do this allowing
takes
why always this move
but at least I got the pawn to a better
place for me okay sixth idea
Knight D4 as well oh that was so good
this is a higher the highest quality
game well
very very strategic
quite well yes
interesting
okay the safe option allowing Bishop E6
see his speed skills here
um let's come over
so I have two minor pieces for
uh The Rook
oops
he's moving the effing duck as far away
as
let's go Eric possible
oh [ __ ]
I'm not versed in end games
I hung upon he didn't take it though
oh I hung the thing
oops
making this much harder than it needs to
be
it's still winning I think
okay let's just try and meet uh no
no it's a funny ending
oh no what did I do
King and pawn vs king is winning I think
no it's not no no no no no
I think it is
I just couldn't change my mind in time
now instead we have a situation I know
I've studied some duck Theory before
so the the trick is to advance upon
and to shoulder out the king I'm pretty
sure this is winning
oops
I messed up a little bit
it's all about keeping opposition
there we go
yeah this is winning
wow we have a very theoretical duck
ending this is the end game we started
out the stream with okay
so in normal chess it's not winning if
the if the white King's like in front of
the pond and the dog chess it seems like
it should be even more of a draw but the
thing is white gets on zuk zwang because
after I'll show it
um we're basically playing out the idea
of it after this
let's say like keep blocking the pawn
we get to a position like this this
looks like stalemate but in Duck chess
you're allowed to move your king to a
square that's attacked like there's no
official concept of check
so
it's actually my first time having this
end game in a real
real game
um
so if white wanted to play this and this
then I would just play this or no I
wouldn't um
I would just start pushing the pawn
and the king would just be stuck
eventually if I make a queen that's
going to be losing
so
it's hard to wrap the mind around but
uh
yeah somehow like the king
the king will continually shoulder the
the white king
and I saw this I actually learned about
this like months ago
because I saw an end game that had a
very similar situation
so anyway uh
if this goes on YouTube
this is a duck chess ending that
everyone should know
King and Pawn
I think is winning regardless as long as
I don't lose a pawn
it's really close to losing the pawn
thank you hamster ham